où tu en es toi sentimentalement avait
pas vu depuis un petit moment mais ça va
changer
c'est à dire donc fait toujours bon
c'est pas non mais en plus avec le
confinement des compliqué que je
trouvais personnes quand je voyais plein
de monde est né depuis des années en
fait en fait mais ça ne change pas grand
chose mais ça l'est d'autant confiture
toi tu as des vues sur quelqu'un parce
que je te dire ce que je te regarde tous
les vendredis je trouve de plus en plus
belle ouais ouais là vous aimez ces
p'tits loups que c'est un peu gilbert
mais conseille le petit oiseau détendue
c'est sympa mais avec tous les amis que
j'avais vous avez des amis célibataires
évidemment qu'ils ont peut-être craqué
sur daniela ce que éventuellement vous
pourriez faire le matchmaker celui par
la sers gestion là qui vous parle de moi
pardon je donne beaucoup mais fait une
passe et malheureusement ils ne sont
plus de ce monde
je suis en train de devenir un peu
cougar pascal or moi je l'inscris
complètement pour heintinga liés à la
maison tant à gauche qu'à dhamar halal
halal chez moi ce que je peux faire
si vous avez des élections oui la maxime
de maxime est en couple avec julien
robert je vous rappelle qu'il est avec
julia robert key ce qu'on va chercher
encore est-ce que vous avez des vues
retrait rond puisque vous avez débuts
sur quelqu'un je dis là pour l'instant
mon trip c'est hallucinant mais c'est en
train de rajeunir les connecte pas c'est
autre chose
ford est confuse et du milieu d'abord la
des conseillers du minou d'abord
qu'est-ce qui pousse à vélo sexy sexy
n'était pas comme ça
il a changé un moment les uv ça vous
tapez sur le guardian a bien qui va vous
l'amour et ses teintes ont applaudi
regarde quand on a beau tracteur sont à
envisager de le conduire les affaires
non mais agnel mois
cette année je vous dis c'est pas
admissible à 2020 c'est vrai que vous
ayez galoche quelqu'un à 2020 soit dans
un mois dans un mois mais je n'aurais je
crois j'ai quelques temps vous rigole
pas il est vrai nom il est bien vivant
et je peux vous dire il bouge encore et
le parti s'appelle comment va me
raconter noie pas bon et il s'appelle
pas non plus kevin na waie accord non
seuil à cannes hier
il ya quelques années la rentrée y aller
très bas bonnet et bonnet vous monsieur
également mené à bien par exemple lui et
c'est son ex chéri alors attendez vous
senti mentalement je suis en couple
depuis quelques années mais ces [ __ ]
bah tant pis je regrette infiniment
les micros alors oui alors à moi c'est
le petit look baroudeur et tous les
salariés d'un poilu baroudeur fêter ça
fait longtemps qu'il est vraiment
confiné enfin quand même que j'ai bien
très bien sans la rue encore j'ai très
peur de s'inverser la comédie c'est pas
mike horn et mike berrebi lui la mairie
qui brille elle a les yeux libraire vous
avez des yeux qui brillent vous avez
mais là vous avez tapé dedans mais yann
est ce que je sais que je sais que ça va
à peu près la même coiffure c'est
maintenant mais c'est vrai vous avez
vous êtes vous déjà vous êtes appliqué
de coiffure en tout cas ça m'a gardé le
même âge même yann dépassant pas bien ce
que c'est votre fils daniel est ce que
c'est votre style et daniel c'est le
style de tout le monde et des
merveilleuses ordinaire non c'est vrai
elle a beaucoup de répartie à gagner
c'est ce que je vais faire abandonner
qu'on peut pas aller au restaurant ce
moment et je vais vous installer une
petite tape assez bien
bon bout et pour lui il y aura deux
bougies il y en aura une troisième qu'il
faudra retrouver de batoumi on va vers
ça lundi la diva c'est encore la vie et
l'a dit on reprend un point sur ce
couple qui est en train de naître
d'accord qu'un sale et parlante parce
que là bas j'ai mis dans le mille a
vibré en plus ça tout à 1
on l'appelle le meur du sexe des
fichiers
[Applaudissements]